But yeah, Elijah Schaefer is like known piece of So I I'm curious
to see how she cuz if if she's saying he got me really drunk,
I'm like, "Oh, this is like something that he does." Yeah.
All right. Okay. Without further ado, let's let's start looking
through this Elijah Schaefer stuff. All right. I'm going to go
to the first Shimu tweet I saw, I think, first and then we'll
go from there. Cuz I saw I saw Shimu tweet about this and I'm
like, "Wait, what the is happening?" I was so baffled when I
first started seeing this popping up on my timeline cuz it's
like Elijah Schaefer in a hotel or something. It's super confusing.
Okay, pull this up. This is the first tweet I saw on this today.
Elijah Schaefer is having a full breakdown on ex posting and
deleting that his wife and kids are missing and walking around
flooded hotels. Hiest. Okay, so this is the video. >> My
life doesn't make any sense right now, but this is the way back
to my hotel room and it doesn't make any sense. I now have to
leave my hotel room because of a flood. This is very weird. But
what's going on here? Okay, it's very bizarre.
>> I feel like they don't want him in this area. Why the
would you be in this area with all this flooded? Who is this?
This is Elijah Schaper. If you guys don't know who Elijah Schaper
is, he's a either a current or former host at the Blaze, a conservative,
you know, internet commentary place. Sort of like the Daily Wire,
but more Christian bend, right? You know, Jack Doardia, if that's
even how you pronounce his name, is worse than an online. He's
a scumbag who's abusing >> This is him. Anyway, this guy's
got accusations in the background. He's had to like leave networks
over assault allegations, he's got he's basically like when people
talk about how conservatives are like druggies who cheat on their
wives and engage in like gay and are totally degenerate. It's
like this guy they're thinking about and Milo, this guy is like
the straight version of Milo behind the scenes. None of the charisma
in front of the scenes. Okay. But behind the scenes, he's like
Milo. He's like the version of Milo. Okay. Yes, he is. Glenn
Beck fired him from the blaze for harassment or assault. He's
had multiple allegations like this. He's apparently cheated on
his wife multiple times. Okay. Just a total DJ. And it turns
out that possibly that's what led to this situation as
Okay. I guess some water moving.
>> Um, what if it's manually photoshopped? No AI involved.
I mean, you could just use your brain for two seconds and think
about what my position would be on that.
>> Okay, cool. Won't walk in that.
My feet are wet. And then we got some
flooding, I guess. Okay, it's falling on
But [laughter]
what even is going on, right? What even is going on, guys?
>> Oh my god. It's like, what even is water? Is it just
like H2O
thing? Okay,
I can like take a seat
and actually rest.
But then I have some what?
Some diet Dr. Pepper.
>> Oh my god, he's got diet Dr. Pepper
Oh, this guy is
I believe he tweeted after this that he's sober, by the way.
And I feel like everybody's just like, "Dude, come on. Be be
honest. Be honest." Yeah. Somebody says stuck in the back rooms.
That is It is a little bit like a liinal space, isn't it? Little
bit of a liinal space effect going on here, isn't there?
>> No one believes me that my >> So anyway, we got
some of the tweets as well. So, let's take a look at this one.
Uh,
I do not know where my wife and kids are, and I cannot get a
hold of them. They are filed as missing persons. They have gone
missing. Last enforcement confirms someone or sorry, yeah, last
enforcement confirms someone in my household set me up. They
planted drugs and said I was a criminal. This will be a public
trial by the FBI.
What the are you talking about, dog? Dog, what are you saying
right now, dog? Are you Are you good? Are you good? Wait, where's
my Abby tweet?
Oh, where's this stupid Abby tweet? Is it lib Abby? Abby lib.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. These are his deleted posts. I have this in
my history thankfully. Oh my god.
Okay, these are his deleted posts. So, that was the first one.
Okay. I have a horrible suspicion that Elijah Schaefer has killed
his family with the gun he claims is stolen. I feel sick now.
Right off the bat, I will say this was looking like I've got
the JF tweet as well. This was looking like a Mama JF situation.
Okay, he he was posting on Twitter. It starts to look like an
alibi really quickly, right? My wife and kids are gone. This
will be a public trial.
Uh let's see. I'm a victim of serious targeted felony crimes.
I am not. They have kidnapped my family. They have stolen my
money. I will bring justice. I need the public to know. I am
in Virginia. The government is aware. I believe the FBI is trying
to destroy my life and kill me.
Okay. All right.
All right.
My car was recovered by US customs. I am the victim of a serious
set of felonies, including gun theft. Someone from my inner circle
is involved. This is an international probe. I don't know who
I picked off. I have evidence and will prosecute. I can't say
anything else.
Bro, this guy must be on drugs cuz he's aged like a thousand
years in the past two years. Holy.
This guy has aged
I swear this guy looked totally different like a year and a half
ago. A year and a half ago with a little weight to him. He looked
totally different. How old is he? 40. He's got to be 40, right?
Elijah Schaefer
He's 32. Oh, that's rough.
Hold on. He was taking gym pics like just a little while ago.
Give me a second. What was his gym picture he had going on here?
This does not look like him at all. What the
He's like putting flexing p pictures in the gram. Okay, cuz he
was he was kind of chubby a while back. He's kind of chubby now.
Apparently he's hitting the gym.
God first family, then pursue your calling. You will improve
in all areas if you are physically and mentally healthy. No more
Maybe making some pivot into, you know, self-improvement stuff.
He's 32. This looks different than the video I just saw of him.
This one, he looks way different here. Somehow just looks he
looks like thin.
Not like like his skin is thin. Like I I don't know how to describe
it.
Like he's worn down. Significantly worn
Yeah. I swear I saw some some message from him a year ago. He
was 31. It said 31 a year ago. I think he's 32,
dude. Crazy stuff. Okay,
keep looking. Keep looking.
You said your family was missing. Now it's about the car. I'm
glad you got the car back, but you've been on a coke bender and
the misses took the kids. Coke is for homos, bro. Most pointless
drug I ever did. Absolute weak.
Shut the [__] up, you projecting narcissistic.
Okay. Sorry you did coke and your life. I don't do drugs. I'm
a dad. I'm very concerned, but I've been advised by attorneys
to not make any more statements due to criminal actions against
me and sensitive nature.
Okay.
All right.
Okay. All right. All right. Okay. No, don't go there. All right.
So,
now this was all like kind of crazy. These tweets were coming
out over time during the day. All right. Eventually, it becomes
clear that
he's filed for like divorce or something. Wait, hold on. Before
we do that, we had one post here. Okay. This is in the middle
of the day as well. Okay. Poor Elijah. Does he have the brains
to get away with it? Or is this a real kidnapping and he's being
truthful? [laughter]
This guy is so sick. It's so sick when you realize this guy killed
his wife. Okay, almost certainly killed his wife. It's actually
crazy that he made this
It's actually ill. Like this guy is
this guy is I don't know, man.
OJ complimenting BTK. Some It's something like that. Okay, dude.
Honestly, this that sounds like something a woman would do. Plant
stuff, then run with the kids. Been there a thousand times. Dude,
[laughter]
JF, JF, JF.
Everybody loves JF, guys. Okay, he's the He's the I don't know.
He's the serial killer. We don't think it's like, you know what?
We weren't watching you closely enough. I don't think you're
actually smart enough to get away with it. We got an eye on you
now. It'll be fine. It'll be fine now. We got an eye on you.
It'll be okay.
All right. Now, I've got the next thing I've got is the Shimu
tweet, the most recent ones. Okay.
And I don't know if I'm going to miss any context. I hope not.
I I don't think so, but
maybe we go to the Neuro tweet next. The Neuro tweet thread.
Give me a second. This one. Yes.
So, when is this? This is about
two and a half hours ago. Okay.
Milo comes out and says, "Listen, guys. I'm in contact with Elijah.
I'm I'm talking to him. Okay. I'm I'm giving him like some advice.
Surely Milo is going to help, right? Surely Milo's going to help.
Come on, Milo. You help your buddy out. Let's read it. Milo Yiannopoulos.
I'm in touch with Elijah. I told him to get off the internet
for a couple weeks and go to rehab. It's better for everyone
to just rip the band-aid off. So, I'll share with you over the
next few hours the info doing the rounds in private or at least
what I've been able to confirm.
Spoiler alert, this guy cheated on his wife again. Okay, spoiler
alert. This dude cheated on his wife again.
Now, let's see here. Elijah, I see I've seen a dossier someone
put together. Everything is coming out. My advice is to check
yourself into a facility sooner rather than later. There may
be a life for you after this, but it's going to totally it's
going to depend on being totally honest about all the details,
and it's going to require sympathy. As far as I can see, drug
addiction is the only card you have left to play. If I By the
way, Milo's just going to share his strategy advice. Okay.
If I were you, I would go out of my way to be as generous and
decent with the wife and kids. Um, be sorry. Be generous and
decent with the wife and kids. This cross filing in other states
for divorce is insultingly childish and stupid. So, what I've
heard is Elijah Schaefer, and I haven't seen this substantiated
anywhere else other than right here, but Milo's bringing it up.
Elijah Schaefer, his wife was divorcing him, and apparently he
went and filed in a different state so he could say, "I initiated
the divorce." Like, I was unaware. I initiated the divorce. No,
I'm breaking up with you. No, I quit. You can't fire me. I quit.
Wow. Thank you, Elijah. Very cool.
All right. So, that's by the way, catch people up as they come
in because obviously people are going to be behind. Okay. So,
Limlet just asked just tuned in. Why is B relevant again? We're
going over some Elijah Schaefer stuff. All right.
And I'm glad you're here, Limlet. But we're going to need people
to catch everything up. Did he kill his wife? I do not believe
so. I believe his wife divorced him and then he filed in a different
state and then he's having some drugfueled nervous breakdown
around that. Okay.
It's very likely that he is just He said she's missing. He did
say she's missing, but I do believe they're getting divorced.
I do believe it's coming out that
he cheated on her again for like the 80th time. Okay.
Like everybody knows that Elijah Schaefer is a complete piece
of I think the thing that shocks people most about Elijah Schaefer
when they meet in private is they go, "Oh, did you know that
Elijah Schaefer cheated on his wife?" And people are like, "Yeah,
I knew that. Wait, who do you cheat with?" And then they have
eight different people. There could be a circle of eight people.
They all know eight different people that Elijah Schaefer cheated
with. Okay, that's that's like what shocks people is not that
he cheated. It's that they all have a different person he cheated
with. All right.
Total.
He does love cheating on his wife. Just like you said, Lab, he
is a total piece of
All right.
Hold on. Let me see. Gonna
I don't know if you want to hop in for this, Lab. I'll hop in
the Discord just in case.
Hold on. This could be funny because I know you know some of
these people or I know you have some connections to some of these
people. If you want to, if you just want to watch, it's all fine.
Shout out my podcast with Emily. Wait, is your podcast with Emily
still going on? You can join if you want. Um, okay.
You you did do a podcast before. Maybe you guys talked about
how Elijah Schaefer's a piece of [__] Anyway,
So, Milo references this cross filing of the divorce. All right.
And again, I believe that is him filing in a different state
because he wanted to say he initiated the divorce. Okay. Observers
will be asking, "Haven't you put the poor through enough?" The
investors don't matter. If they met you and still wrote you a
check, that's on them. I'm sure it will be a while before you
are ready to start putting your life back together. And when
you are, I will help you. I've been trying to signal to you for
the past year or so to cut the and talk to me. I was hoping everybody
could avoid this.
Oh god. Milo's painting himself as like a fixer here who could
have helped. Yeah,
very very crazy.
Could avoid this.
Okay, that's we're we're getting the next line here. You may
wish to be offline for the next week or two. What do you mean?
Cease and assisting people right now, but I got my car back,
so that's good. Are you stupid? What do you mean? Wait, just
seeing this the top of this. Hey man, I'm going through some
tough things. Can you help me here? What dossier shot you a call?
And Pilo responds, "Your tweets have been so erratic and insane
that people are asking if you killed your family. There's a dossier
being circulated that reveals all the details about Rift's collapse,
your drinking/substance abuse, the affair WITH SARAH STARK."
OH, HOLD
>> Known Canadian Sarah Stark.
You love to see it. Okay. Treatment of your wife, habits, and
perversions. alleged prostitution, your wife filing for divorce,
and then you filing back in different in a different state so
you can make out that you dumped her.
It is safe to assume that everything about your life is about
to hit the internet. Start again at the beginning of my text
now that you know that that now that you know this, you won't
take it. But my very strong advice is that you get off the internet
for 2 weeks and check into rehab and be very very nice to your
wife. Whether or not you have a professional future at all depends
on it. Nobody believes this horseshit you're posting about your
car either. You got away with being man uh with being a maniac
for a while, but the bill is now due.
You are a very poor liar. It is not your forte. You should find
another profession. One of which you only need to tell only need
the truth.
If your husband doesn't know, oh now, now let's start with Sarah
Stark. And then he goes to his text with Sarah Stark. Okay.
something your enemies for the story.
Oh god, is what he said before this. Oh boy. If your husband
doesn't know, now is the time. I understand that you won't see
it like this for a long time. But as you can see from the above,
it is better for everyone that things come out in one burst today
instead of met metastasizing over weeks. Don't let him find out
from somebody else.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Now,
here's the [__] funny thing about this one. Okay,
I believe there is a dossier because I have future sight, as
in I live more than 2 hours away from the past. All right, and
I've seen that there's apparently a recording of Sarasto basically
admitting to an affair.
Now, could that be AI generated or something? Possibly. Possibly.
But it it sounds pretty believable.
Um, also I have no idea if yank the band yank the band-aid off
might not be a good idea here, by the way.
Right. Yank the band-aid off might be a really bad
It might be that somebody's like blackmailing him and Milo's
gotten wind of like the blackmail, right? And he's saying, "No,
I just want chaos. Burn it all down." Right? I would never trust
Milo's I would never trust Milo's advice ever. I just I wouldn't
ever. Sarah Stock claimed to be a virgin. No. Before marriage,
possibly. Sarah Stock's an obvious grifter. Yes, she is.
Okay.
Let's see here. In February 2025.
I'm trying to see when I should switch over to the Shimu stuff.
Trying to keep an eye on this as well,
cuz Shimu's got some of the other. Oh, no. It's Milo right here
with the recording. Okay, never mind. It's right here. All right,
we keep going with the Milo thread. In February 2025, Sarah Stark
and Elijah Schaefer began sleeping together. The affair ended
on the day she got engaged about six months later. In that time,
they experienced multiple pregnancy scares. It is one It is alleged
by one former acquaintance that Sarah got at least one abortion.
Oh my god.
But isn't Isn't life sacred? What? What? What? Huh? Huh?
At least one abort should
stock and Schaefer heads on the day they met at the CPAC conference.
In recordings of Stark confessing the affair, she claims large
amounts of alcohol were involved. They told each other they loved
one another. Elijah told her that he was thinking of leaving
his wife for her. Stark's husband met with Schaefer met Schaefer
many times but did not know about their relationship when he
proposed. In this recording, Stark can be heard admitting to
the affair, adding that she does not plan to tell her husband
about it. Oh god. Do we read the text first or is this the transcript
of the
11 minute? Oh, hold on. Okay, now this recording is
5 minutes long. I believe these are transcripts of this recording.
Oh no.
Right. These must these look like transcripts of a recording,
right? Like timestamps. Transcripts for a recording. So, some
very long recording that somebody was doing while talking to
Sarah Stark, apparently.
Oh, boy. Oh, boy. Can we listen to it? Yes. I'm just looking
at this and trying to set up the framing for it. Okay.
All right. Let's uh give me a second. I'm going to hit pause
on the music because the music is a little little overbearing
on this. We're going to listen to the music.
>> We're going to turn it up as well. Hold on. That's maxed.
Turn up like this >> at all because
>> Okay, we'll roll back to the beginning. I hear I'd know
that. I'd know that vocal fry anywhere. >> Take any accountability
at all because like it obviously was. >> Now, immediately
dispelled are any concerns I have about this being an AI recording.
There is no way that AI could
reproduce
the vocal fry we see from Sarah Stark.
my fault too what happened between us but even that was like
not
like I don't know I felt
>> even that was like not
what's up how's it going >> hey I like
>> I'll roll this recording back did you have you not followed
any of this stuff so far today >> uh no
>> okay well it's looking juicy it's it's looking very
like
I don't know I I don't know how 20 2026 is is kicking off like
this.
It's actually crazy. Everybody had all these blackmail files
on everyone else and they all just decided in 2026 at the same
time to drop all of them.
>> You know what I think is really interesting about Elijah
Schaefer
>> is that he's sort of like a known like in this like
one of the first >> Wait, is that is he the guy who literally
assaulted your friend? >> Yes. He's also the guy that literally
Destiny was telling everyone to Lauren
well, at this point, what conservative influencer hasn't read
Lauren Southern? >> No, honestly. >> I'm so sorry.
>> Honestly, [laughter] but actually, is it Paul Joseph
Watson? Is it Andrew Tate and now Elijah Schaefer? I think uh
Lauren has been raped multiple times, but he Dusty was straight
up telling everyone that Lauren Southern was raped by Elijah
Schaefer.
>> Yeah, you could tell he wanted to talk about it on his
stream as well. Like he brought it up multiple times that Elijah
Schaefer's, right? >> Yeah. Um >> I don't think he
said the name on the stream, but I I have no doubt that he told
multiple people that that happened.
>> Yeah. And he definitely did assault my friend Emily
as well. So,
>> cuz did you say that on stream or did you just say I
feel like you said she got groped like on non-conensually? >> Her
friend, she doesn't want to come off as someone who's like a
victim, but her
um who's like kind of known also. He's like a gay black guy in
the sphere. I forget his name, but um he's like the >> Oh,
I know that guy. Yeah, they're both they're both cutting like
they're both cashing like huge checks from Israel. Emily and
uh yeah, the gay black guy.
Uh >> those guys are those those two are some of the biggest
Zionists on the planet. It's very very cool. >> I don't
know if Emily's cashing a check. Her boyfriend's just very like
from Israel. So I think that that's the vibe there. But >> she'd
be cashing checks. She'd be in that uh that Bill Aman crew.
>> right. She going to all those Bill Aman fundraisers
in the Hamptons, chilling with those people. Xavier Xavier or
something like that is >> Yeah, something like that. Something
like that. But um
but yeah, Elijah Schaefer is like known piece of so I I'm curious
to see how she because if if she's saying he got me really drunk,
I'm like, "Oh, this is like something that he does." Yeah. He's
like, "Yeah, he's a
>> yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I forget his last name, but I I do
think it's like the classical composer, isn't it?" Or am I am
I totally making that up? Xavier. >> I I don't know. It's
something I don't even think I don't know if Xavier is right.
I don't maybe >> Xavier something. >> Yeah. I love
how women act like they wouldn't grape us if the roles were reversed.
If the roles were reversed, baby, I'm doing it now. >> I'm
doing it now. What role reversal do we need?
>> It's uh it's this guy right here, right? >> this
is the black guy. >> No, this is this is another gay black
guy she hangs out with, which is so
>> Okay, sorry. cuz I was like, "This is definitely a gay
black guy she hangs out >> Yeah, it's another one. He wears
the like light blue contacts.
>> He's like the son of a senator or something. Hers Walker's
son.
>> OH,
OKAY. WEIRD. >> YEAH. She's like collecting gay black men,
I guess.
That's how you know a is like cool is if she has like a bunch
of
gay men surrounding her.
>> Yeah. Okay. Thank you. >> Literally. Thank you.
I'm on Twitch, just so you know. On Twitch currently. >> Well,
I don't I'm not saying anything
>> I I just figured I'd give you a heads up. Listen, I
didn't give I didn't give uh Queen came in here, dropped an Fler
instantly yesterday, so >> Well, he can he has the pass.
[laughter] Didn't think about that. >> Obviously was >> here.
Let's um I'm going to restart this right now. I'm gonna turn
this up as much as I can. It is very >> accountability
at all because like I it obviously was my fault, too. what happened
between us. But even that was like not
like like I don't know. I felt like it was like
like he got me like very intoxicated. Like I don't even like
remember most of it. And I was even like
He got me like very intoxicated.
Like I dude, it's like
I I can just
I can hear like I can actually smell the Xanax coming off of
her breath as she speaks in this. It's like crazy how Zans
>> Okay. Well, I
>> think people with that mid-curve IQ sound like
>> remember most of it. And I was even like thinking back
cuz it was like at CPAC the two nights.
Um we were there and the second night I was like breaking out
and like a rash. And so he's like oh like get some benadryil.
It'll help with the rash. And like now I'm thinking back and
I was like that's probably why I like blacked out because he
like intentionally gave me benadryil and like fed me a bunch
of shots and stuff. And like obviously it's like stupid on my
part
>> um to like go along. Was it benadryil? Do we believe
it was benadryil? Hey, I've got benadryil for you. Take this
pill. Hey, take this unmarked pill right now. You'll be fine.
>> Yeah. You know, but at the same time, it's like he obviously
like knew what he was doing.
>> So, he had he had it in his mind. Benadryl, what like
does that just make it increases like the toxicity or something
like get you really? >> Yeah. Like Yeah. like mixing like
a drug like that with alcohol.
>> When was C what what was it? Cpek.
>> That was when I very first met him [clears throat] in
February.
>> I've taken a benadryil and drank before and it has not
got me more drunk.
>> Yeah, I think a lot of people have taken like allergy
medicine and drank. Um I don't think there's necessar I think
there's there's like sleepy interactions. I think possibly. Yeah,
it makes Benadrol makes you some
>> but not the alcohol might you might make you more sleepy,
right? >> Yeah, but that doesn't mean you But sleepiness
isn't blacking out. That's a different mechanism of your brain.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. She drinks lean. No, lean would be cough syrup, not benadryil.
Anyway, um what am I trying to say here? Oh, I wonder who the
other person in this conversation is. Who the [__]
the other guy in this conversation that recorded this?
>> Somebody's recording this conversation.
>> Dude, I want to
>> first met him in February.
where was he back? I don't even remember >> Oh. Oh, that
was in DC. Oh, I got you. Yeah. [sighs and gasps]
>> Banad drill for a breakout.
>> Yeah. Okay.
That's crazy. Yeah, he is. He's he I >> Once again, like
I'm saying like I'm not saying I don't like have any
fault in that. Like I like it like definitely like ate me up
for like a long time.
>> I feel very bad about it still.
>> Um but
>> Damn.
Yeah. That's
>> It sounds like she's sober now. She has to understand
how stupid it would be to tell anybody in her field about this,
right?
Like, like literally, it sounds like she's on the phone even.
I don't think she's in person there, right? Can we do we agree
on that? Does it sound like she's on the phone? >> Yeah,
she's on the phone.
>> Like, how in the could you be so stupid to tell this?
Unless basically you thought you assumed it was coming out and
you're like giving somebody the story or something or you're
intentionally bleaking it. I don't I don't know. I wonder if
I wonder if it's because someone else said something
>> I wonder when this was recorded because if someone else
said something about how Elijah Schaer like assaulted someone
and they were asking girls that they knew he'd been with it would
make sense that she would have this response and be like well
it was also my fault and I did think maybe he got me a little
drunk but >> yeah I I don't know it's it's wild to me that
this is um that she's saying this she has to understand that
this would be almost certainly she's risking it being recorded
and being released Like, yeah, maybe maybe it's a, you know,
crisis of conscience. She's heard about other
>> it's tough. And I mean, I don't know. I don't know how
you feel about the guy now, but it's like it's probably worse
that you don't
>> Yes. CPAC 2025. >> Like, the more that you learn
about him and know who he really is, it probably makes the whole
thing worse a little
>> Oh, yeah. For sure.
>> Yeah. What is >> I mean, I just don't want anything
to do with him. Like, I just >> I I get you. Yeah, I totally
get you. What What did he say about his family? Like cuz obviously
he has like a family and kids. What was his excuse with that
though? Like how would he justify that? >> He's like He
was like, "Oh, my wife doesn't care. She lets me like
she lets me run run free or whatever. She doesn't care as long
as cuz I like take such good care of her and she just lets me
be a man and like do what I want and blah blah blah." Like he
was like saying that stuff. Yeah.
Do we believe that based on the the current divorce that we're
hearing about? Do we are we believing that one?
I don't know. I feel like either way, not a very conservative
outlook, I'd >> Says like the wife doesn't care. Wow.
>> So, he has an open relationship, huh?
That's crazy.
Which I mean,
>> did you ever question that or like >> I was like
that's definitely not like I like realized that's not true, >> But
um also like >> at the time like it seemed like I don't
know just like the way he acted and everyone acted around him
and the things he would say around girls and almost like seemed
like that was true. Does [laughter] that make sense?
And like obviously like I
deeply
regret that but also like I'm not a like I mean that's like a
horri a horrible thing but it's not like I really am like sleeping
around or have been. So
>> yeah I mean you don't
you don't >> so Elijah so Sarah by Elijah or what? I mean
it sounds like they had first and then the next night she had
more alcohol with him. and also medication.
That's what it sounds like to me. She didn't have a husband back
then, she wasn't even engaged yet, but she obviously if she was
about to be engaged, which happens 6 months after they started,
then she had a boyfriend. Sure. >> Defend yourself. >> It's
kind of Yeah, I know. But I'm just saying like it's kind of just
like not even true for like anyone who knows me.
>> yeah. I mean, you just had a fling with Elijah and that's
I don't know. I guess he got upset about it. He was going He's
just exaggerating. Yeah. I mean,
>> did you
I guess you're not going to >> I'm sorry.
>> tell anyone, huh? Or
>> I guess I was going to ask like would you tell your
husband? I guess this is before your husband, right? >> Might
have to check this out. >> Yeah. No, we weren't engaged.
>> Oh, okay.
>> But no, I'm not telling anyone.
And like I was like,
like I said, like very intoxicated.
>> he [clears throat] said like it was a couple times like
you were traveling around and like maybe in DC and New York and
STUFF LIKE THAT. >> AH
ah
he's telling people about it. I see.
I see. He's telling people about it. Yeah. We just saw this uh
Tequila Sunset just linked this. [laughter] I won. Congratulations
from the team at at Rift at the Rift TV. The haters were wrong
again,
[laughter] dude. This is crazy. Hold on. They did a segment together.
>> Sarah Stark, journalist at
and controversial firebrand. You >> wait, I thought slightly
offensive is his brand, too. Oh, so he hired her. Okay. quite
the last 24 hours after you had diabolically decided to take
the defensive stance for xenophobic
immigration nationalism, right? This identity of xenophobia.
It's crazy, but apparently it's working right now. Number one,
how are you doing with the newfound fame over this appearance
on
>> I've been doing great. The leftist meltdown has been
hilarious. There's people losing their minds saying that Jubilee
is platforming fascism. And actually, I think that Jubilee might
have taken down my video on purpose from their Tik Tok account
because they got so much backlash just because
>> God I
This guy is just a larer too, isn't he? Um, man, probably. It's
sometimes hard to tell.
I do know that just most people don't take him seriously at all.
Like I feel like was it I'm trying to think I want to say last
year I think him Fuentes Myin and Sneo maybe were thinking about
doing a podcast together.
I don't know how Elijah got rolled into that originally. I get
the feeling that Fentes doesn't take this guy seriously at all.
Never has.
What's going on with all the conservative right-wingers behind
the scenes? I mean clearly they're just ultra degenerate.
That's like a ton of these people are just ultra degenerate behind
the scenes. Like they're totally from
>> this is all the conservative culture Tim Pool was talking
about all those years ago. Yeah. Well, I mean Milo's been talking
about it. Lauren Southern talked about it. Everybody's talked
about it. How all these conservative dudes are like just total
degens behind the scenes the whole time.
I'm guessing when we heard about the influencer stuff before
about this guy, it it probably ties back to this Rift TV thing
where he got like sponsored to go and make his own platform.
I wonder if that'll come out that that's like, you know, like
a foreign interest spending on that cuz he he made his own thing.
It sounds like he was concerned about that when he was texting
with Milo. We can go back to this whole text chain again.
We can continue on with this now. I just I wanted to see if there'd
be anything funny here, but I I'm guessing it's just going to
be like completely boring the whole time. Guessing that's probably
more where that's going to go. So, we'll go back to Milo. A man
who can entertain. All right. A man who does
Give me a second. Let's Let's go back to some of these guys.
So, Stock alleges that Schaefer got me like very intoxicated.
Got me like very Hold on. got me like very intoxicated
uh and that she does not remember all the events of the evening.
She adds that he gave her benadryil ostensibly for a rash but
perhaps also to get her further intoxicated. She drank a bunch
of shots and blacked out. Schaefer constantly questioned Stark's
faith at the same time as or so uh at the same time as or so
several former employees allege masquerading as an Orthodox Christian
himself wearing oversized religious. When he met Stark's husband,
Schaefer kissed him on the forehead in the manner of a priest.
Elijah Elijah Schaefer's affair with Sarah Stark will come as
a surprise to some observers, many of whom are convinced that
Schaefer is, or at least was gay. Others regard him as a co cookie
cutter, drunk, and womanizer. Both groups are correct. Yes, I've
heard this as well, that he does not just assault women. I've
Have you heard this? Have you heard this, Lav? >> No, I
haven't. >> That he definitely has. I've I've heard that
he is also that he's like behind the scenes pretty obviously.
Schaefer says he had a twink phase before he got married. A twink
is a slender young male who enjoys being aggressively anally
by an older, active, usually more muscled partner. This period
seems to coincide with Schaer's time as a youth pastor. Oh, Milo's
got some experience with this now. Now we're in Milo's realm.
Okay.
being by his pastor.
We're We're in Milo's
domain. Okay, he knows everything about this. Little known fact
about Schaefer is that he attended church with and grew up around
Benny Johnson at whose house Schaefer attended sleepovers while
they both attended Cavalry Chapel. Schaefer left the church in
a hurry left the church in a hurry when he discovered having
when he was discovered having sex with another man. This is I
do believe this is probably not
uh yeah if only you knew. Waiter, give me some details. Give
me some details. I won't leak them on stream but I need I need
some details.
cuz I think Milo is going on with going off with everything.
Okay, despite his own past, one of Schaefer's favorite
subjects is Nick Fuentes's
a subject Schaefer returns to again and again. According to Sarah
Stark, who comments in the second recording on how much Elijah
talks about Fentes in private. Oh,
>> bringing on.
>> Okay, hold on. This is still maxed out volume, by the
way, >> while bringing on one of his enemies or >> Yeah.
And then um Beardson did a little bit of a stream and talked
a lot of [__] about Elijah for saying like, "Oh,
like I feel like he's constantly like subweeting the grapers
and like trying to talk [__] about grippers without
saying anything directly."
And but it's like kind of weird cuz even Beard's like, "Yeah,
like I like Elijah though. Like I don't like I don't have a reason
to like dislike him, but like this needs to stop. Like it's cringe.
I don't know. He was kind of like in the middle like that." So
I was it beard didn't even have like any of the examples where
Elijah said like so much worse.
>> You know what I mean? Like he he wasn't even aware of
this.
>> So that's what I'm saying. Even Beard did a whole stream
about this. He didn't seem to like he nearly knew anything about
it. So I just kind of feel like most of them
>> I don't know. I guess >> I was thinking like if
Nick knew like how much I just talked about him. Like he's Well,
Eliza will go around like telling people Nick's gay. >> Oh,
really?
>> Yeah. He's like said that before in like a room be like,
"Yeah, I mean like I think it's definitely true that he is, you
know, gay or whatever, but he has his own things." Like he's
like totally said that before >> cuz that I'm saying like
those things make me I don't want to believe Nick's gay like
you know what I mean like you know how I feel but those half
of what Milo says is completely madeup tea. I do think the the
gay relationship with Benny Johnson I'd need to see some substantiation
of obviously I realize he takes the chance when whenever
Milo has a scoop. This is something you'll learn as a drama farmer
yourselves. Okay. Whenever Milo has a scoop, he always slides
in some lie to with somebody. So when he has something that he
knows is true that he's got like the scoop on, he will slide
in a lie about somebody he hates just to with them, right?
Like literally he's got this scoop, he's got some texts with
Elijah, he sent text to Sarah, and then what he's going to do
is he's going to go, "Hey, Benny Johnson, remember how you with
me? Well, guess what? I'm going to use this to substantiate that
you're a
which I do believe, by the way, that Benny Johnson is gay." Okay,
I do believe that Benny Johnson is gay. I just don't know if
they're gay together or if they were gay together. All right,
>> things like those clues that Elijah's leaving and always
these comments and then the fact that like Nick doesn't just
crush him when he like counter signals or whatever. It's like
I just feel like is it does he know something? Like what does
Elijah have that he's allowed to exist this long or what? >> Because
and maybe you're right, nobody's just paying attention, but >> No,
I some of the tweets like I just think that like
no one's paid attention to Elijah and they don't care what he
says [laughter] about Nick. >> So then why
>> why does he want to go around saying he's gay? Like
why would he say that?
>> Because he talks cuz he's jealous of Nicki. Like he's
extremely jealous of >> It's like obvious. >> Like
he's like talks so much about Nick for no reason.
>> Why Why do you think he's jealous? I have to study for
an archaeology quiz. I'll be back later if I'm not
blissfully
>> All right, see you later. Thanks for coming on. Bye.
>> And he's on his generational run.
>> And then like Elijah will say things like, well, you
know, Nick is like he's better at doing a show than me, but I'm
the one who's like way good way better at running a business.
Like he doesn't know how to run a business.
like he says all these like copes basically cuz he sees himself
as in competition with him and then he would get like so jealous
when like I obviously like would say like no like
Nick's like the leader of the movement like he like literally
crashed out because I said to him that like oh like Nick's the
leader of the movement you're not or something
>> now that >> oh this is brutal she's like in private
it talking to somebody who
is recording the conversation and she's just Dude,
this is a rough one. Okay, this is a very rough one.
I She's She's showing herself to be like so untrustworthy here
that she's just talking to some random dude. He's not obviously
not popular enough that I can even know his voice off the top
of my head. Some random guy, right? Who the [__]
is she talking to telling all these like secrets to that are
going to destroy careers?
clearly not somebody who could even know these secrets in the
first place, right? She's just thrown them out like candy to
people. >> That's starting to make a little more sense
because I couldn't understand like where there was this switch
where he was like condemning anybody in the company that uh was
like liked Nick or watched his clips or was like even just like
mildly supportive. He's like, "You're either on my side or Nick's
side and they were crashing about you and Mike and anybody else
that whatever." And then they were trying to say like you're
a Groer, too. you like to me and I was like no I mean he's just
right about stuff. I don't even watch his stuff but like whenever
I see his stuff like he is right and he's better than you. Like
that's just like a fact. But it was like you you're either on
my side or his side and now it makes more sense. Like if you
had said that to him, I can understand why he would have got
even more jealous. That makes >> Oh yeah. >> Okay.
That [laughter]
[snorts] now that makes more sense about the crash out cuz I
like I remember confronting him one time and be like, "Dude,
aren't you friends with this guy? Like why do you keep why do
you keep this up?" You know, like every every show was like a
dig like, "Yeah, but they're all like incelss and you know, none
of them are white and they, you know, they're not Chads like
me." It was like every time. And I was like, "Why do you care
so much?" He there was like a while I don't even I haven't even
watched his show in a long time but like the last time I was
watching it or I would like check in every single time just seething
about [laughter]
and like no it was totally like he was
>> am I am I starting to pick up why she
started signaling to gropers so much like so much more? Am I
picking up it was just to with Elijah Schaefer?
Do you guys think I I feel like I'm picking this up. Am I the
only one picking this >> Genuinely like I don't think there's
any other time he was like genuinely anatomy. But when I said
that when I I think he was just like we it was when like it was
after SAS and Kevin Povic came on the show and then we all went
out to dinner >> and then I was kind of like trying to
convince Kevin to be like a griper.
>> Yeah. Yeah, basically cuz he was asking me these questions
about Nick and I'm thinking like, dude, if we can convince like
Kevin to be based in Red Pill, then maybe he can like convince
his brother. Like I'm thinking like that way, right? >> And
then and so I'm just like telling like, "No, no, that's not true
about Nick. This is like what really happened or whatever." And
I'm like trying to explain things to him. And then Elijah's like
budding into our conversation be like, "Oh, no." But like Nick
is like,
>> "Dude, it actually makes it so much
Oh, when when they had that right-wing like egirl civil war thing
happen with her and Morgan Ariel and uh whatever the Emily does
Emily saves America whatever when those people are all fighting
I now I feel like Sarah was just trying to be like I'm the best
trad wife I'm like the I'm the one who isn't like you who isn't
run through like you guys
right am I
I feel like she was like totally looking down on those people
and it's crazy that that exact time she's cheating on her husband.
she had cheated on her her future husband already >> and
like just like you know saying h stuff and then so I'm just like
defending
defending Nick [snorts] and then Elijah gets all mad and he's
like oh why are you defending him so hard you act like he's your
boyfriend like you have a crush on [laughter]
>> he's like genuinely like >> upset at me and then
that made me kind of mad and I'm like
>> I'm like basically I like told him to like humble himself
and I'm like sorry Lick Nick's the leader of the movement Like
no one even knows what Rift TV is. Like I think [laughter]
I I think I like said something that like I'm not saying we don't
have like a part to play or anything, but like don't pretend
like you have more influence than him.
>> And then cuz that's what he was trying to claim is that
like he has no real influence or something. Like he clearly has
like way more influence. He has like all these lawyer loyal followers
and like a lot of them are infiltrating. Like I know them. >> He
has a ton of influence. It's just like it's undeniable. Even
if you hate him, it's undeniable. Wow. >> Yeah. Exactly.
And then he was like denying this and whatever. And then after
he was like generally kind of mad at me and the next day he like
sat me down, gave me a talk about like bad mouthing the company
in front of people who aren't in it or something.
so she was in she was in the I think what they used to call it.
I I actually don't know the difference. So Elijah Schaefer had
a channel called what was it? Politically Oh, I just saw it.
Uh what was Slightly Offensive? Slightly offensive was what he
was going under. Okay. And then they must have rebranded to Rift
TV or something at some point, although he still has the slightly
offensive channel as well on YouTube. But then they start this
Rift TV thing and she he must have hired Sarah at some
and she's in the company basically being like, "Dude, nobody
cares about your Nick Fantasw."
That's that's brutal, man. That's [__] That's awful.
Slightly offensive. Lost all sponsorship. Then he got funded
to be Rift TV. Yeah, that's what I figured. I I do want to know
who funded Rift TV. Okay. Who funded Rift TV? That's just true
though. Yeah, but it's a little different when it's like one
of your employee. Okay, that's that's maybe true. All right,
Koser, imagine imagine you're like um you're like Burger King
in the '90s. You're getting totally blown out by McDonald's and
like one of your executives is just sitting at some table with
investors talking about how awesome McDonald's is and how they're
like the leaders in the industry. It's like, okay, I get it,
but like we're we represent a company, okay? We represent a company.
Show some loyalty to the company. I get it. I I get it. I understand.
I get why he would be annoyed. All right. Show some loyalty.
Anyway, then, you know, maybe if that's the worst she did after
he, you know, got her drunk and [__] her, then, you
know, maybe he got off easy.
By the way, I've confirmed that Schaefer's wife and children
are safe. Oh, that's an hour ago. All right. There are too many
examples of outrageous hypocrisy to list. But here's the kind
of thing Stark was posting online when she was nearly weekly
and for 6 months cheating on her boyfriend with Elijah Schaefer.
It is not known whether she insisted her husband wait for marriage.
I am officially a Catholic. A crisis rex.
Wow.
Not cool, man.
Is this the dumb from that Jubilee episode? Yes. Sarah Stark
is the person from that Jubilee episode. Sarah Stark
Let me see if we can find >> Hey everyone, >> he's
the person from from was this one that went viral. >> What's
the problem with xenophobic nationalism? Don't you think that's
better for Americans in general?
>> Nationalism is better. >> We should [laughter]
have a coherent culture. Everyone should be a part of the same.
We should have assimilation.
>> She's the one who Eerite just debated as well at um
at the >> You get to choose what the culture is. We already
have a dominant culture based on European and Christian values
and identity. That is the dominant culture. It's rooted in. >> You
covered the Jake Shields crash out. I covered a little bit of
Nick talking about him, but Nick was just talking about how doesn't
like Jake Shields
>> and I it just wasn't all that interesting to be honest.
This is way more interesting to be honest with you. Okay, this
is infinitely more interesting. I'm sure we're going to find
way more tweets, way more everything about Elijah Schaefer as
we continue to cover this. By the way, I'm sure this is going
to be awesome. By the way, you guys find funny stuff. I would
want to go and look at was Sarah Stock talking about people who
cheated, hedonism, this kind of thing. Cheating, drugs, hedonism,
alcohol, all of these things. Has she been posting about those?
You know, February to
uh August of 2025. Hello. Who's this? >> This bad little
shorty is going viral on right-wing Twitter.
>> Wow. Jeez. Very cool. I just noticed now now that I've
covered her a little bit that they're imitating the the what
do you call it? The vocal fry. Very cool. All right.
Anyway, we we continue on with the
Okay. So, actually that's not quite true. We do know if she made
him wait or we do know if she made him wait. She did because
Sarasto's husband believed he was marrying a virgin. That's what
she told him or at least allowed him to believe. What we don't
know is how she explained not being intact on the big night.
I mean, vigorous. Come on,
dude. That's That's a little weird. That's a little weird.
>> I stand with Elijah.
oh, you just doing the Howling Mutant tweet? I did get the mutant
tweet as well with him. >> Yeah. Yeah. [__]
this. >> That's the Howling mutant tweet. Sucks, >> I
guess I'm the only one brave enough to say I stand with Elijah
Schaefer.
Very cool. >> Why was she drinking alone with a man she
didn't want to [__] Explain that one to me.
>> I mean, realistically,
she says the second night she was drugged or something, but it's
like the second night and then a six-month relationship allegedly.
We'll see if she makes a statement cuz she so far since this
has started popping off. Crickets. We got crickets at the moment.
Okay.
Nothing but crickets over here on the Sarah Stock
Twitter feed.
Oh boy. So on here, vigorous horse riding has been known to claim
to claim the
himemenial integrity.
Is this how you say it? The hymenial integrity of teen girls,
though this is less common than women like to suggest.
Uh Elijah Schaefer's drinking, drug taking, and extrammarital
affairs have been relentless for the duration of his marriage.
a union hastily arranged once he decided to pursue a conservative
media career. One thing hasn't changed from Schaefer's days as
a youth pastor. He still likes things shoved up his bum. His
fetish for is sufficiently well known that it has been disclosed
repeatedly, including by influencer Britney Venty. Uh, can we
get a source on this?
We get a s Can we get a source on this? >> Is this guy
still dying of a brain tumor or did he get better?
>> Milo? Uh, I mean he could he could literally be tweeting
this from a hospital bed like wasted away. He would he would
he would muster the energy to do this, you know? He would. >> Okay.
This guy would be this guy would have like nothing left in life.
He' just be like sitting there 90 lbs and tweeting. Just be like,
"Elijah, you have to you have to go to rehab. I'm giving you
the best advice you'll ever receive. You have to go to rehab
and you also have to leak everything now. This is what you have
to do, okay? It's the only way to save your career. Leak everything
you know right now, Elijah. Trust me, Elijah. I I I'm giving
you the best advice you've ever heard, Elijah. Leak everything
now.
So, I I'm looking for substantiation on this. Okay.
Schaefer owns an electric, which he has taken with him on vacations
to El Salvador and other places. On these trips, he hires and
brags about hiring female prostitutes, but spends much of their
time together being anally mechanically paid by the hookers.
Okay, now I I need to I need to see any substantiation of this
at all
to believe it. But I I want to I just need some substantiation
to believe that. Dude,
>> I just need any substantiation.
Schaefer is on a cocktail of both illegal and prescription drugs,
including peptides and accelerants. He has been blacking out
from excessive alcohol consumption in combination with these
chemicals multiple days per week for years, as he confesses in
this third recording. >> And I'll just say I'm going to
admit I'll just say this. I can't take I can't make you admit
anything, say anything, but I will admit that that I am playing
a role in this and that I am uh that it is immature and that
it should be dealt with differently. And I will also admit outside
of work that yeah, my personal life I I I'm having a hard time
and I'm trying different I'm I'm trying to like figure it out.
Uh, but obviously I am stressed and I'm not I don't I'm not dealing
with it the way I should be and I'm not and it's not always that
I'm up, you know, up till uh 12. Like often times the same it's
the same thing. If I don't drink, then I can't sleep. I can't
sleep more than an hour. I'm tossing. I fall asleep at 6:00 and
it's like it may look like I was drinking the same thing or not.
Do I drink sometimes and too much? Absolutely. Uh, you know,
I consider myself more of like having a binge problem where even
if even if it is only a couple times in a week, it's like, yeah,
I'll black out or whatever. And so that is
weak. Very weak. Out of respect for Schaefer's soon to be ex-wife,
and for the sake of his children, I am not reproducing messages
between the Schaers. Suffice it to say that Elijah's conduct
as a husband and father has been derelictked, frightening, and
neglectful in the extreme.
After years of infidelity, irresponsible, or insensible drunken
rants, abuse, and even being falsely implicated in felonies,
Schaefer's wife filed for divorce in Texas in January. Worried
about his manly public image, Schaefer filed in Florida so he
could pretend he had instigated the divorce.
Wow. So cool,
This is Texas, some Texas thing for looking at, I guess, divorce
appearances, divorce, divorce proceedings, rather. Cool.
Schaefer faces a messy divorce made more difficult because he
is flat broke. He raised money for a new endeavor, Rift TV, at
a $5 million valuation, including one investment of over $250,000.
But that money is already gone, as are the staff. Rift TV is
insolvent, heading for bankruptcy.
As I write to you, dozens of stories about his private modus
operandi are flooding in. They're all the same. Aggressive assault,
proflegate spending, vast quantities of drugs and alcohol, and
at the end of the night, a foreign object in Elijah Schaefer's
rectal canal. Jesus Christ. Here's my Elijah 2 story. Who's this?
Does he show? He does not. Okay, it's just a random random story
with no backing, no name attached. We love these. We love these.
Here's my Elijah 2 story. After an event we hosted with Elijah,
we he sorry, he went out drinking with attendees. He flirted
with college girls and the entire sorry, the entire time and
only took a brief break to FaceTime his wife. He was very drunk.
The next day, one girl from the night told me that Elijah had
put hands in her pants when she told him no multiple times. He
also tried to make her touch him. After she pushed back and told
him no multiple times, he eventually stopped. She didn't want
to make me make a big deal out of it, but I was pretty upset
and I stopped working with Elijah. Elijah claimed he did Coke
on a bong.
Okay, I have no clue if that is even possible. And at one of
the dive bars, I saw him go into the bathroom with literally
10 college girls who were doing Coke.
Crazy. That's awesome. That's awesome. This is this conservatives
Hunter Biden.
Many are saying so. Later today, I'll share what it was like
to work for Rift TV and the vindictive ways Schaefer retaliated
against those who either tried to help him or who spoke out at
the workplace he made them endure. Spoke out about the workplace
he made them endure, rather. Oh, and that BMW, he left it unlocked
with the keys inside. More soon.
More soon. Wait, more now? What are we doing, Milo?
Oh, he has been posting. He's been He literally has not stopped
posting. He's posting every 3 minutes. Okay, cool, cool, cool,
cool. All right, let's uh let's check this out. As a side note,
I'm profoundly disgusted by Sarasto's plainly counterfeit Catholicism
and appalled to my core that she had the nerve to rope the Holy
Father into her deceptions. Behavior like this is why we had
witch trials. [laughter] >> That's right. >> I forgot
she got her marriage blessed by the Pope and she tweeted about
it. Hold
Uh x.com Sarah Sarah Seto Pope highly recommend getting your
marriage blessed by the Pope. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
So cool. Okay, we continue. Sarah's just called has called just
about every woman on the internet. Oh, how do women do it? So
frightening. Okay, that's crazy coming from Milo specifically.
Okay. The fact that Milo
felt he could tweet that and he can tweet that. Sorry. The fact
that he felt like empowered to tweet that is just hilarious to
me.
It's like the pot knowing that it's black and calling everybody
else black and just being like,
"Yeah, it's dude."
Oh, for those forgetful students, I'm happy to issue a refresher.
People who weren't around in 2016 don't seem to understand that
you don't with Milo.
Okay. I
sometimes sometimes. How can you call me messy when I'm the only
person doing any cleanup at all? Milo the messy they call him.
What is this? Okay.
Somebody just talking. You conservative ladies want to be careful
gloating want to be careful gloating your group chats about Sarah
Stock when I know half a dozen of you Elijah too. Ooh. Uh-oh.
The biggest lingering question is whether the abortion alleged
by Sarah Stock's former coworker in fact happened. To be precise,
this ex-colague said at least one. I don't have proof either
way, although she and Elijah demonstrabably had multiple pregnancy
Do we have anything else on this? Is this I wanted to we we went
to the end of this cuz we just wanted to, you know, catch up
in case there's anything else breaking tonight. Let me see. Shimoo
got anything? Otherwise, we're going to move on. Cover some other
[__] I assume you watch video of him walking through
the
>> Yes. Yes, we did. >> No one believes me that my
life doesn't make any sense.
>> What do I have? What do we have?
>> Dr. Pepper. Let's go. >> This is the way back
to my hotel room, and it doesn't make any sense. I now have to
leave my hotel room because of a
This is very weird.
But what's going on here? Okay, it's very bizarre. So, there's
some I guess some water moving here.
Okay, cool. Won't walk in that.
My feet are wet.
>> Flooding, I guess. >> Walks directly into this
>> pulling on me,
>> dude. [laughter]
what even is going on, right?
There's a
>> thing. Okay,
at least I can like take a seat
and actually rest.
But then I have some what?
>> Some diet. Dr. Pepper. No one believe.
>> Uh,
why is no one else there? Cuz it's flooded and they like they're
trying to stop the flooding from happening, but they're probably
calling a plumber and there's no reason for anyone else to be
there right now. What are they going to do? Oh god, liinal spaces
are scary,
I don't know if there's anything else going on here with all
this. Let me see. We might just move on to the Ethan Klein stuff
real quick.
Schaefer finally sober. Elijah Schaefer gives a sober update
after his druginduced traumatic day. My wife divorced me and
took my kids, and I have no idea where they are. I'm sober. I'm
sad. I have a good support. Thank you for uh thank you for everyone
supporting me during this rough season. I'll get through it.
Wow. I think this is Yeah, everything. Okay.
Yeah, that I think that's everything up to the minute. I don't
know if there's anything else on the Elijah Schaefer stuff, guys.
I think that's everything up to the minute right now.